think i think when you get to like i
think when you get to be like a one
percent guy right he's he's top five
percent whatever they run multi-million
dollar businesses they probably know a
lot of [ __ ] you don't to be honest
unless you're on that same level but
like
if i was dating a guy that's a
billionaire or a millionaire i would
trust his judge i'm sorry you have to
remember that that's the one percent you
know how many of us are really gonna
touch the one percenter right
like that's a combination of you're
super you're very clearly super
intelligent but that's also luck like
not everyone is super intelligent makes
it so it's kind of like oh it's not
you're right it's partially luck but i
have not seen many people make a 20 30
year career without being somewhat smart
and subway driven right yeah yeah yeah
yeah
like you know it's like five minutes of
fame right like a year two years
okay wait um okay so the next super chat
so none of you would taking a spanking
from your significant other i'm not i'm
not i mean
okay yesterday this this show to make
this educational and y'all trying to
make it about sex
please relax
i told you i was profiting off of all of
your beauty what do you mean i told you
hey
i know i'm pretty but i know i don't fit
the male gaze at the end of the day
yeah yeah what are you talking about
they said okay
he kept saying that and i'm like i would
love to get spanked you know like she's
like when she let it get smacked or
whatever the [ __ ] he says spanker
okay this is my next next one next one
next one this show is about to make
pearl realize those chicks from fresh
and fit are the norm not the outlier the
wretchedness is internal fellas period
sorry guys
nothing um other women's disrespectful
to us sir
here okay
[Music]
um okay so i'm gonna do one last
question to close out the show
would you rather
date a guy that's flat broke
but the hot like the finest man you've
ever seen in your life no
or
super rich you never have to pay a bill
again
but no he's not toxic
but ugly yeah but ugly like he's shorter
than you
kind of overweight
i have met the finest man that i will
ever meet and he was a thug and in and
out of jail and a drug dealer and he was
the sexiest man ever in my life and i
would never be with him
because
what is he doing with his life nothing
what that drug money looking happy
medium what's that drug money looking
like
not [ __ ] cause he keeps going into jail
and he's gotta pay bail
you're right you're right he's single an
option
none of the above
literally like
i don't know that just that just sounds
like a mess i feel like
you know if i could hold my own and i'm
independent i'm probably gonna go with
the attractive person yeah
um
but like genuinely attractiveness for me
has to be your personality so physically
yeah if you that's fine you could go you
could go with that like the personality
is included in the attraction good
because
you could be really fine but an [ __ ]
so like it's really not going to be
worth it to me if you broke and mean
like pick a struggle but
okay so you so you would pick hot you
would pick rich
you get to pick one hot
rich
okay okay that's okay
but the bills the bills what's the thing
with myself and what about my kids
generational wealth i can trust that i
can hold it down
like yeah but i don't help him i listen
i come from a perspective where it's
like
i don't like i personally don't want my
kids to ever have to ask me like can i
do this and i don't want to say no like
can i go to this school can i do this no
like
with the career that i'm going into like
probably like i'm going to make 150 000
at the most like yeah personally so it's
like
if i'm really looking at like
the big picture
then i'm gonna go in the long run you
want to be able to help your kids that
makes sense because of my personal
experience yeah okay so so hot rich
but whatever i'm attracted to like no
you're you're attracted to the heart
okay
so you would you would have to hold it
down myself like it's not a thing what's
your what's your degree and i'm just
curious
events
does that does that how much does that
make
you
you can make up to like 50k like even
more like a law it depends on what part
of the events you get into that you can
get into hosting a lot of things
marketing
pr so if you're at 50k though that's
like one but that's the minimum like
there's a lot you can get up so you can
get you can like there's a lot of people
that make up to 100k like
right right it depends
you'd be cool with the guy you'd be cool
with him being like a stair
you'd be cool with him being like a
stay-at-home husband to be honest i'm
like a career woman so yeah okay okay so
okay so hot hot rich
for me
if he has
something going for him because
essentially he doesn't not the hot one
if he doesn't honestly
i'm gonna keep it 100 with you if he
doesn't have nothing going for him
i wouldn't choose either because i'm not
about to you would be by yourself yeah
i'm not about to be with someone that i
don't find
i wouldn't want to just resort to
being with somebody because they have
money i'm gonna have my own i'm gonna
work hard for my own and have my own but
i don't wanna resort to struggling with
somebody because i struggled my whole
life struggling with somebody that
because they're attractive well but the
the see for me like that would come at
the cost of not having kids and that
like i couldn't i could not i would i
think my like purpose on this earth is
to be a mother someday yeah so if i
didn't get to do like i
i would pick the hot one because i have
like the sexual chemistry of them right
no because i have family money so i
don't need it
she said i got money already not not not
now but some did so like for me like i
don't have family money but like i also
like i'm but also i'm italian i grow up
in a culture that's like pop out as many
as you can yeah and i mean i'm not gonna
do that yeah like if i did i would have
probably three kids by now yeah
well you're only 22. yeah but she said
by now
amen when do your parents start yeah
like i don't have that to fall back on
so if we're going off with children like
i want to have at least three at least
yeah like so that's why you'd pick the
rich guy because you'd have to afford it
yeah because like i also feel like i
have
like i'm such a motherly personality and
just in general like i've i've always
felt like part of my purpose on this
earth is to be a mom you know what i'm
going to switch mine because i just know
if the guy was laying around the house
all the day i would not be attracted to
him no matter yeah yeah
he is i switched my answer
you're still in the same spot shut up
before i say some [ __ ] that i'm gonna
regret oh my gosh
i'll just say like when it comes to the
person being ugly like if that includes
their personality i'm not going to be
able to withstand that emotionally
but if they have a good personality and
they're ugly man i've been with some
ugly [ __ ] before so
you know it's not going to be that much
of a problem because no matter what like
as soon as i see you're a good person
you have a good heart yeah i'm always
going to be attracted to you yeah
exactly exactly
okay well